les jambes sur l'évolution en le
retirant de la vie politique
salut à tous et bienvenue pour cette
deuxième vidéo sur la crise au venezuela
lors de la première vidéo on s'était
arrêté fin 2012 à ce moment là chavez
est atteint d'un cancer que l'on sait
incurable et démissionne la
présidentielle anticipée qui suit porte
au pouvoir son successeur nicolas maduro
qui est élu de justesse avec 50,6 % des
voix chavez lui décède en mars 2013 et à
partir de ce moment là une crise
économique éclate je vous propose dans
un premier temps de voir la chronologie
de la crise économique puis de voir les
explications des chavistes et des anti
chavistes et enfin de voir la crise
politique qui en a découlé
c'est parti la crise économique devient
visible à partir de 2013 petit à petit
de nombreux biens de consommation
courante commence à manquer papier
toilette les rimes et aussi casse
automobile ou médicaments les files
d'attentes s'allongent devant les
magasins tandis que les étals se vide et
en 2017 80% des produits de base
subissent des ruptures de stocks entre
les dévaluation du bolivar qui ont
augmenté les prix des produits importés
et la loi de l'offre et de la demande
les prix flambent et l'inflation elle
atteint des sommets vertigineux jusqu'à
atteindre 800 % en 2016
à cause de cette inflation de nombreuses
couches de la population se retrouve en
difficulté et la pauvreté qui était en
régression jusqu'au début des années
2010 remonte et finit par toucher 76 %
de la population en 2015 selon certaines
études et jeudi selon certaines études
car la publication des chiffres
officiels est interdite depuis le début
de la crise pour ne pas favoriser la
déstabilisation du pays voilà pour les
faits bruts qui met tout le monde
d'accord
mais l'origine de la crise elle ne fait
pas consensus au venezuela
chaque qu'en avançant sa propre
explication pour les chavistes
l'explication à la crise économique et
simple il s'agirait d'une tentative de
déstabilisation organisée par les états
unis pour mettre les opposants dénoncé
comme fasciste au pouvoir cet argument
s'appuie notamment sur des précédents en
amérique latine en effet pendant la
guerre froide
les usa se sont assuré qu'aucun
gouvernement socialiste ne prennent le
pouvoir dans cette partie du monde qui
considéraient comme leur chasse gardée
il y a notamment eu le cas du chili au
début des années 70 où la droite et le
patronat en lien
les etats unis ont organisé des grèves
et des pénuries avant de finalement opté
pour la manière forte en faisant un coup
d'état militaire via le tristement
célèbre général pinochet pour empêcher
le gouvernement socialiste de salvador
allende de réformer le pays
il se produirait la même chose au
venezuela d'où les pénuries et la
crainte clairement exprimée par le
gouvernement à partir de 2016 d'une
invasion étrangère
le souvenir de la tentative de coup
d'état raté en 2002 contre chavez par le
patronat la droite est aussi encore
vivace et peut venir accréditer cette
thèse
mais si on regarde qui est dans
l'opposition il n'y a pas de quoi crier
au fascisme
la principale structure la mood la table
de l'unité démocratique en français est
une coalition de partis allant du
centre-droit à l'extrême gauche
mondialiste
parmi ceux ci on retrouve les deux
anciens grands partis de centre gauche
et de droite à coppet et l'action
démocratique et des parties plus petit
souvent de centre gauche
sociaux-libéraux volonté populaire ou
primero justicia il ya également des
structures d'extrême gauche comme la
kaiser radical regroupant d'anciens
guérilleros marxistes
parmi les anciens membres de la
collection toujours dans l'opposition on
peut citer le mas est l'un des rares
aura deux structures d'extrême gauche
qui ont aussi d'anciens guérilleros dans
leurs rangs on peut aussi citer le dr le
troisième ancien grand parti avec la
coopec et l'action démocratique
à noter également que le mas est un
ancien soutien à chavez si cette
alliance gauche droite vous paraît
étrange dites vous que chaque pays a ses
particularités et ses alliances un peu
bizarre vu de l'extérieur par exemple le
parti communiste vénézuélien ketcha
liste dans les années 90 avait fait
partie d'une alliance
le shérif perron où il côtoyait du dr et
le mas tous deux faisant aujourd'hui
partie de l'opposition soit disant
fasciste en fait il n'ya pas une
opposition capitaliste ou fascistes pro
américaine face à un gouvernement
socialiste et révolutionnaire
il ya plusieurs oppositions qui ont
réussi à se rassembler quant à la menace
fasciste il s'agit en fait d'un vieil
argument chez certains à gauche qui
permet à la fois de mobiliser son propre
camp de stigmatiser l'ennemi et de
détourner l'attention à peu de frais
pour l'opposition et les observateurs
extérieurs explications à la crise
économique est tout autre il s'agit de
plusieurs effectifs cumul principalement
liée à la baisse du prix du pétrole
depuis 2008 comme on l'a vu dans la
précédente vidéo
jusqu'à cette date toute la politique
chavistes est basé sur la rente
pétrolière et sur un pétrole cher
cette baisse a notamment eu un impact
sur les réserves de change détenues par
la kadiri l'organisme d'état qui
s'occupe des conversions entre monnaies
pour résumer à grands traits quand une
entreprise achète du pétrole vénézuélien
et le payant dollars l'acadie vie en
récupère une partie et en a des
quantités importantes pour les achats
extérieurs et pour la conversion de
devises
et quand le venezuela importe des biens
de consommation qui les payent aux
fournisseurs étrangers en bolivar et ses
fournisseurs demande ensuite à
l'académie de convertir ses bolivar dans
leur monnaie nationale ou en dollars le
problème vient du fait que le prix du
baril est passé de 140 dollars à la
veille de la crise mondiale à 50 dollars
en 2009
il s'est ensuite un peu redressé avant
de rechuter à partir de 2014
cette dégringolade à petit appétit
entraîné une baisse des réserves de
devises et l'acadie vite mais de plus en
plus longtemps à couvert sur les bruits
venant d'autres monnaies ce qui pose
problème aux entreprises qui importe au
venezuela
car à part les grands firmes qui ont des
liquidités importantes les entreprises
fonctionnent sur des fonds de roulement
et ont besoin d'être payé rapidement si
elles ne veulent pas être insolvable
c'est une cause de faillite classique
chez les entreprises pourtant viables et
cela refroidit considérablement l'envi
de commercer avec le venezuela autre
élément la baisse du cours du pétrole et
donc des rentrées fiscales qui y sont
liés a obligé le pays à faire marcher la
planche à billets au créer
artificiellement des moyens de paiement
cette solution n'est jamais la bonne car
elle dévalue la manne est écrit
rapidement l'inflation qui n'a pas tardé
à se produire avec le bolivar à cela
s'ajoute un problème endémique au
venezuela la corruption chavez a
notamment été élu sur la lutte contre
celle-ci
mais après une quinzaine d'années au
pouvoir le tennis m'a générer sa propre
élite l'abolît bourgeoisie qui s'est
incrusté dans tous les rouages de l'état
et a généré sa propre corruption acadie
vie est l'un des foyers de cet
enrichissement illégal
ainsi on a découvert en 2013 que
l'acadie vie versé de l'argent à des
sociétés fantômes
après enquête les autorités estiment que
cette fraude a coûté jusqu'à 20
milliards de dollars par an soit 4% du
pib et on estime que 40% des changes qui
se sont fait vers le dollar était en
fait le fait de ces sociétés fantômes
l'autre composante de la crise est
directement dus à la mauvaise gestion de
chavistes et une compréhension des
mécanismes économiques en 2002 après les
grèves antigouvernementales on se
rappelle que le gouvernement avait viré
19000 employés de la paix des bsa
la compagnie pétrolière nationale à
cause du manque d'entretien de personnel
compétent et d'investissement la
compagnie a vu sa production décliner
fortement le pays produisait 3,4
millions de barils par jour en 1998 et
seulement 2 4 millions à la mi 2016 ce
problème de gestion a aussi touché le
secteur productif
d'abord le gouvernement a imposé des
prix contrôlés si bien qu'avec le temps
l'inflation a rogné les marges des
entreprises
les poussant à la faillite et forçant
ensuite le pays a importé des biens de
consommation par exemple en 2000 le pays
importait pour 1,4 milliard d'euros
qu'ont denrées alimentaires et 6 5
milliards en 2013
paradoxalement le pays est aujourd'hui
plus dépendants de l'extérieur qu'à voir
l'arrivée de chavez au pouvoir alors que
celui ci a fait de l'indépendance
nationale une priorité bien certains
programmes sociaux baisse du prix du
pétrole et mauvaise gestion très
clairement même si d'habitude je ne suis
pas fan des explications tout économique
je pense que cette explication là est la
bonne l'explication de chavistes et trop
caricatural pour être vrai et cette
explication économique correspond à
l'économie du pays
toujours est-il en tout cas que cette
crise économique a fini par dégénérer en
crise politique
la crise politique éclate clairement fin
2015 mais on peut apercevoir les
prémices dès 2014
en février de cette année là les
premières manifestations contre
l'insécurité et les pénuries ont lieu
elles donnent lieu à une quarantaine de
morts à cause de bande d'extrémistes de
part et d'autre l'un des leaders de
l'opposition et membre de volonté
populaire
leopoldo lopez qui avait appelé aux
manifestations et voulait les utiliser
pour pousser le gouvernement dehors et
arrêtés et jugés responsables des morts
et des émeutes et prend 14 années de
prison pour terrorisme et homicide
cette condamnation a dénoncé au niveau
international comme une
instrumentalisation politique
l'opposition n'est pas la seule à subir
la pression de schiste les médias eux se
sont vus intimer l'ordre de ne parler ni
des manifestations ce qui inciterait à
la violence ni des pénuries acte qui
serait considéré par le gouvernement
comme un acte de propagande pour
déstabiliser le pays et serait passible
d'amendé parmi les prémices on peut
aussi citer l'arrestation d' antonio
ledezma maire de caracas figure de
l'opposition et membre de la mode pour
tentative de coup d'état
il n'ya bien sûr aucune preuve de cette
tentative de coup d'état et ledesma qui
a toujours en prison mais fatalement
avec la crise économique le pouvoir
chaviste perd une partie de son soutien
populaire
cela se traduit dans les urnes en
décembre 2015 dans la victoire de
l'opposition aux législatives
les opposants décroche alors 112 sièges
sur 167 la crise politique
éclate ouvertement et une guérilla
juridique se déclenche depuis
l'instauration de la vème république par
chavez
le parlement dispose de différents
pouvoirs selon la majorité obtenue avec
sa majorité de 112 députés l'opposition
atteint le seuil des deux tiers qui
donne le droit au parlement de
déclencher un référendum révocatoire
contre le président mais quelques
semaines après les élections la justice
annule l'élection de trois députés de la
mode faisant perdre à celle ci la
possibilité de convoquer le référendum
ne désespérant pas l'opposition tentent
de déclencher le référendum par un autre
mécanisme légal celui de la pétition
populaire
ce mécanisme compliqué constitué de
plusieurs étapes d'abord il faut réunir
au moins deux cent mille signatures soit
1 % du corps électoral
puis 4 millions de signatures soit 20 %
du corps électoral et ensuite le
référendum doit avoir lieu avant la mi
mandat soit le 10 janvier 2017 au plus
tard passé cette date le référendum
n'est plus pleinement révocatoire il ne
déclenche plus d'élections
présidentielles anticipées en cas de
sucre et le vice-président prenant
l'intérim jusqu'aux élections normales
prévus fin 2018
l'opposition a réussi la première étape
en réunissant 1,8 million de signatures
en mai 2010
soit dix fois plus que nécessaire étape
suivante la récolte de 4 millions de
signatures devaient avoir lieu sur trois
jours fin octobre sachant que cette
vénézuélien sur dix veulent un
changement de gouvernement cette étape
devait être une simple formalité mais la
collecte a été annulée au dernier moment
par le conseil national électoral
cette annulation fait que le référendum
ne pourra pas se tenir avant le 10
janvier 2010 est clairement le régime
fait tout pour éviter d'être évincé en
jouant la montre le gouvernement n'est
pas en reste dans cette guérilla légal
et après l'annulation de l'élection de
trois des piliers de la mood à cause de
doutes sur le scrutin
toutes les décisions prises par le
parlement sont considérés comme invalide
clairement le parlement ne sert plus à
rien également cherchant à recréer un
lien direct avec le peuple
la d'euros qui a déjà une émission
politique comme chavez en son temps a
décidé fin 2016 de lancer en parallèle
sa propre émission de radio dédiée à la
salsa la situation connaît une nouvelle
accélération depuis mars 2017
on l'a vu le parlement ne sert plus à
rien et fin mars la cour suprême l'a
acté en s'arrogeant les pouvoirs
législatifs et en levant l'immunité des
députés
la mesure a soulevé l'indignation aux
niveaux national et international et la
cour suprême a fait marche arrière
quelques jours plus tard après cette
décision
l'opposition semble avoir abandonné tout
espoir de changement par les voies
légales qui ont toutes été essayées est
systématiquement mise en échec par des
manoeuvres du régime le régime
d'ailleurs n'entend pas non plus et
c'est contester dans la rue la dure aux
évoquant dernièrement la possibilité
d'armer la milice bolivarienne voyant
dans cette contestation de rue une
menace pour le pays
les manifestations qui ont lieu depuis
début avril 2017 commence d'ailleurs à
faire des morts et on peut craindre un
scénario similaire à celui de février
2014 le gouvernement risquant de faire
porter le chapeau aux leaders de
l'opposition pour les éliminer on peut
même imaginer le gouvernement
s'arrogeait de nouveaux pouvoirs en
raison de risques que ces manifestations
fera courir pour la sécurité du pays au
final le chavisme aura considérablement
abîmé la démocratie vénézuélienne
alors que le pays à défaut d'être
parfait était l'un des plus stables du
continent sud américain tout en ayant
ruiné son économie alors qu'il était
aussi l'un des plus riches grâce à son
sous sol et dans cette affaire maduro
n'est pas le seul coupable
la crise née de la politique menée
pendant les années de chavez qui a
quelque part eu la chance lui de décéder
avant d'avoir à être confronté aux
conséquences de sa gestion clientéliste
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas encore dire
que le venezuela est une dictature et
manifestations ne sont pas interdites
l'armée et la milice me libérer
ne sont pas encore intervenus et le
pouvoir fait encore demi tour sur
certains points face aux pressions
internationales mais il ya clairement
une dérive extrêmement autoritaire qui
ne présage rien de bon surtout quand on
se rappelle en plus que l'armée est
politisée l'opposition elle aujourd'hui
essayer toutes les voies légales pour
chasser les chavistes de pouvoir sans
succès et se retrouve acculé face à un
régime qui instrumentalise et les
institutions politiques et judiciaires
pour rester au pouvoir
ce régime appuyés sur son discours
socialiste aux forts relents de guerre
froide la fois arc bouté sur son
idéologie et sur ses intérêts en tendant
à lâcher le pouvoir
et aujourd'hui on ne voit pas quelle
peut être la conclusion de l'histoire et
bien voilà vous savez à peu près tout ce
qu'il ya à savoir sur la crise
économique et politique que traverse le
venezuela
du moins jusqu'à la mi avril 2017 il ne
me reste plus qu'à vous dire portez vous
bien et à la prochaine
[Musique]